Your Willow Walker says the rest of the
country music is just biding rap and,
and acting like they are so, well,
I think it was a little bit of that,
but I think at one point in time it was
a little that a lot of rappers would
look at guys like Waylon Jennings and
Johnny Cash and old school gangster
country guys, outlaw country
is way different from,
yeah, I love outlaw country.
You can't tell me Waylon Jennings,
Kris Kristofferson, Willie Nelson,
Johnny Cash aren't kicking it. Like
that's what the fuck is that right. But,
but that's,
that's not the same as you allocate
and Annelie be through your songs and
talking about cowboy boots and said
air force ones. No, not the same.
There's something about the almond
brothers midnight rider and you know,
whipping post that's radically different
than you just sing it about your Ford
and, and you know, and
rafting on Saturday. Yeah.
I don't think people even understand
tied to the whipping posts.
You can't fake that song. Quit when
they came at me about the NRA interview.
Um, last year, every day I smoked a joint,
woke up and laughed and listened to
that record like every single day.
I just wanted you guys to know.
It didn't bother me any.
My wife just told me to
shut up talking to you all.
We went shooting a lot more and we play
almond brothers whipping posts every
morning because I had to remind
myself that this is normal,
that you are being done like this publicly
because you are disagreeing with the
system that people have agreed to that
you don't agree to and it's okay not to
agree.
So the Harmon brothers really got me
through that segment has stopped me from
punching a lot of bourgeoisie
black people in the face.
Well you're a proponent of your,
your right to carry a gun. Yeah.
And I'm a lover of the U s nine
states constitution as a whole of of,
of all our rights and amendments.
But in particular, you know,
the first and second amendment rights
matter to me as an African American,
as an and as an American, first and
foremost, as an African American,
I've only been free 55 years.
My parents were born in apartheid.
And as an American,
we are,
we are a country that broke off from
what we felt like with the tyranny of the
monarchy.
And we did that because farmers in
guns [inaudible] wage guerrilla warfare
against at that time when the largest
armies and navies in the world.
So I honor that by continuing to
be in the spirit of those farmers,
you know, in the, in the
continuance of Crispus addicts,
the first person who died American
revolution was a black man. You know.
So for me,
I would dishonor those patriots
who started this country
at Christmas attics. I,
with dishonor.
The lineage is an African American who's
only 55 years in a freedom by giving
government and my gun pet. That's
not something I believe in. Um,
government is people pro.
Part of the problem with given government
anything is that they're just people.
They're not something special.
Absolutely not flawless. Absolutely.
Give People Power over you and
theirs they'll, they will, I mean,
this is not saying we should stockpile
guns and point them at the government.
Know if people have guns, it's way harder
to just take over since the absolute,
that shit happens all the time in other
countries and it does happen. Absolutely.
People get occupied and governments
turn on them at government's changed the
rules and put places that were democracies
are no longer so absolutely that's
real. And we're never far from
it. Is it safe as you feel?
You're never far from it.
But I think what we need more of
is people like you that are, uh,
that are reasonable,
very educated in the matter
of or articulate person who
comes from a place where
they don't expect that argument come
from. Yeah, I understand. You know,
like think about left wing people are
Democratic People, progressive people.
You always think,
you know,
you think about democratic
people overwhelmingly being
appreciated by the black
community and you always associate
them with being anti gun. Yeah.
That's a common thing. So when a guy
like you steps out and says, no, no,
I think it's a disservice to
take this right away. Absolutely.
If I didn't support it and fight for it.
I've been,
I've been an African American
40 40,000 years now. Right.
I have no democrats.
Primarily my entire life.
I'm from the south in particular the
southeast Alabama, Georgia, Florida.
I have never known a black male
Democrat that was working class at,
did not own a weapon. Mm. Not that.
So I'm going to follow the
examples of my grandfather.
I'm not going to listen to the National
Party in their rhetoric about DRM in the
population.
I think obviously we can agree that we
would all love it if we never needed guns.
Yeah, of course. Yeah. Right.
Of course. Who wouldn't?
I'd rather not need it than be prepared
though. They're not be prepared. Sure.
Read right. Better to have it, not
to need it to needed not to have it.
And the part of the country
I'm from and what you do often.
Like I'm from a party country. I grew
up fishing, hunting and growing food.
My sister, girls who don't get to
hunter's regularly now still fish,
occasionally shouts out to Greg Street
when our biggest t J's down there.
So great fishermen.
Right?
But this is this normal in my part of the
country as not having straws and being
able to smoke in public and
in places like La is it just,
it's not that big of a deal. You
know, you, you, you know in my,
in my mind state a household
should have five guns, right?
You should have a revolver,
shove a semi automatic for fueling
your wife carrying out, you know,
in public he used to have a shotgun and
just cause there's a great all around
going to have, whether it's
burglars are vermin, you know,
you should have bolt action rifles, some
course case cash got to kill your meat.
You should have a semiautomatic rifle,
you know,
defending against here and there just
to fuck off on Sundays and show your
homeboys was dick bigger.
But what should,
what you should not do is give
up your right to own with. Yeah.
Or use them on people.
That's the thing about using them
on people is that it's so rare,
but so horrific and so,
so common for something that's so
horrific and everybody's against it.
But I don't,
I don't understand how you would
ever buy taking guns. I mean,
you'd have to take all the guns
away to stop that from home.
But how are you going to do,
how are you going to do that?
Criminals are going to give up of course.
Huh?
So there's no way the regular people
should probably not do that. That's,
that's where it gets squirrely.
It's like,
how are you going to get those guns
from the criminals? You're not,
you're not going to, you're not
going to joke. Well we can do though.
And I will say as an owner, you get
lazy. Sometimes you don't train enough.
We should try and more. And
that doesn't mean, you know,
he'll try to be the quickest draw
and you practice it, you know?
But what you want to do is make sure you
know what you're doing with your weapon.
Make sure you know how to clean your
weapon, makes you not a store you weapon.
And I took my son and my
nephew, yeah, shooting.
I'm about to start taking my 11 year
old girl Michael shooting because I want
them to know what they do if they see
a gun. So we've already went through,
what do you do if you're somewhere
and you see a gun, how do,
how do you get out of that situation
and get other kids out of that situation
and let an adult know all that comes
with it. You know? And you know,
the strange thing to me is that my mother,
when she was in high school,
was actually taught how to shoot
a rifle, right? Because the NRA,
which is now vilified and hate it
for four reasons, some deservedly so.
So I'm not,
they used to have big programs in public
schools to make sure that children new
firearm safety. So my mother school
and other schools benefited from that.
I don't care if it was just that sheet
of paper that told you gun safety before
you went and arrange.
That was just a piece of propaganda
they did that was better for the overall
public.
So I tend to say as Americans,
we've gotten away from
stuff like trades in school.
We've gotten away from different options
beside funneling our kids into college
debt.
And we've also gotten away from basic
training such as balancing a checkbook,
basic home economics.
So how do you make a Lasagna at home
by herself and stuff like gun gun,
gun shooting and archery. I think that
if those things return to public school,
you get a safer and more
confident student body.
You get a reduction on things
like bullying and bullshit,
and you get an increase on itself.
Propel interest of children,
and you start to me to grow
at scholars that excel.
But do you do, do you really, how
was it going to stop bullying?
Just by knowing that more kids know how
to use guns. Guns don't stop bullying. No.
Boxing class stops bullying pimps.
He said that no one wants to fight.
Somebody going to fight back.